آه
[يضحك]
[موسيقى]
يمكنك رمي الأبقار من 5 أبقار في سيونجنام دونج بمقاطعة تشونج تشونج.
اااااااااااااااااااااااااااااااااااااااااااااااااااا
إنه أمر جيد حقًا على كلا الجانبين ، لذا فإن هؤلاء الأشخاص يعطونني 10 اشتراكات.
[موسيقى]
الأورام هي الشيء الخاص بك ، كستناء الخردل العميق
انخرط عامل البناء في الانتماء ، وفي أسابيع هذا الجهد ، لا يمكن تجاوز Boryeong.
مياه البحيرة الكمية تذكر جميعًا بعض الملصقات
آه ، مرسيليا للوطن والشعب
على الفور ، تحرك سونغ عادة للأمام مرة أخرى.
إذا كان الأمر مهمًا ، فقد مات وجعله الضجيج أقوى.
يجب أن أعطيها لأختي كثيرًا ، أعطني الذهب
القليل من التهاني على قصد موت الشعب
أنت بحاجة إلى معرفة
اه اه
بعد إخلاء المدخل أمر زعيم الرفيق بعباراتنا الرئيسية 0
نصيحة من خادم الرفيق القائد قال إن حب حزبنا للشعب كما هو.
أصبحت قوتها ، قاع التيروصور ، الكنيسة في كوريا منتشرة بتعليق الأغنام وشهدت هذه التعويذة جدًا
حفرة في الأرض
Yangdeok Jjigo ، مشهورة كقرية من العصور القديمة
الرفيق تشوي ، الذي ليس خادمًا ، يسأل عن الحشرات حتى في الطابق الأول من الثقة.
إذا كان العمال يستخدمون الريح في الطعام
يخدم مع قلب فتى شينو العروس ، ويترك شيئًا أكثر أهمية لأطفاله
أول شيء أفعله هو التنظيم ، ثم لدي قبعة 4
إذا رأيت Zed ، فاقرأه بعد أن يتم فحصك للحصول على وظيفة إلى جانب علاج جميع جون.
قل أنه صراع 1
التالي هو Hwagi الذي يقود الناس إلى الرقص الحديث The Ja
مع قوة العرض الليلي الصحيحة وأكبر خريطة للزمكان والمكان ، يمكنك القيام بعملك بشكل جيد.
الخمسة الذين يمنعوننا ويخترقون في وتيرتنا ، يخرجون ببعض هوس العمل
إنه لأمر مؤسف أنه كان 100000 وون فقط ، سيد يول.
الكثير من الإشارات إلى فرقة شعبنا التي لم تبصق أوامر تنانين الماء
سكر متوسط ​​منخفض
جاء الجيش الشعبي بشيء آخر لا يصدق لشخصين
قيل لي أن أجد الكثير من الرقص ، وأثناء التعبير عن الرضا ، وضعت خطة لأولئك الذين أدوا 9
الموت
[موسيقى]
آه
اركب حبل أومسو هذا واذهب إلى منتجع التزلج
[موسيقى]
5 استخدامات المؤامرة للتنظيم
ثم رأيت الطلاب الصغار يركبون الخيول في أماكن Kung Won و Zumba الحقيقية.
ألقِ نظرة عليهم والتقط صورًا لكرامتهم وهم يهدأون استعدادًا لداميانغ
أعطى
آه
[موسيقى]
أوه أوه